i did some comedy sets over there in
uh in los angeles
and they had uh
you know it i don't know i got an
argument with this one not an argument
but like
a confrontational moment kind of i guess
um with this one female comedian and she
uh i don't know i've never seen this
woman
seem like she know has ever had an ounce
of joy
in her being but um
anyway uh she got on me like i didn't
have a mask on
i don't know mascot and here's why
because nobody has them on anymore
that's what i'm saying and i'm not i've
now spent time in nashville i spend time
in los angeles
i don't see them anymore
people don't got dumb
and so that's like well you know so she
gets on me and she like kind of like oh
you don't think
we should be wearing masks you know and
i'm like i just
you know nobody has meanwhile
there is a i don't want to say homeless
guy but a guy who
duh you know this dude is not
this guy hasn't been in a laundry room i
bet in probably a year and a half
and he's defecating bro
you know what i'm saying making freaking
body rope dog you feel me
you know what i'm saying serving that
booty isthmus you know what i'm saying
bro
this dude is making them freaking dirty
florida's just rolling out of his boot
and so i uh like nine feet away from us
and this lady's giving me a hard time
so but i stood my ground baby and let my
yappers shine
so that was it was a little conversation
it was kind of exciting though
it was kind of exciting hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one